parce qu'il faut quand même répondre à
la question de la société civile du
statut des politiques il faut pas confus
et ça c'est un serpent de mer
j'ai toujours tout fait pour essayer
d'ouvrir la famille à des gens venus
d'ailleurs
écoutez la première fois qu'une femme a
été nommée ministre de l'économie et des
finances dans l'histoire de la vème
république
c'est christine lagarde c'est la
première fois il y avait eu des femmes
cher edouard cher jean pierre dans les
gouvernements dans vos gouvernements
mais jamais une femme ministre de
l'économie et des finances beaucoup
parmi nous ont fait l'expérience de
l'entrée de la société civile disons les
choses comme édition ça souvent été un
échec
pourquoi parce qu'on ne s'improvise pas
ministre candidat à la présidentielle mr
c'est un métier je veux dire avec y
compris si je suis minoritaire je veux
parler librement
l'engagement politique au plus haut
niveau
c'est bien sûr une passion mais ça
s'apprend voudrait dire qu'on sait mieux
le métier de président de la république
avant de le quitter caen n'y arrivant
pas ce que c'est très difficile de s'y
préparer
deuxième remarque je voudrais tellement
que vous compreniez que ceux qui gagnent
des mandats n'ont pas à s'en excuser
ils se sont présentés des élections ils
ont pris des risques
les français ont voté pour eux je
préférerai toujours même si je ne
partage pas leurs idées
celui quel courage de s'engager plus tôt
que celui call confort d'observer de
parler et de commenter voilà ma vision
du monde
c'est tellement facile
quand on s'est jamais présenté à une
élection d' aller critiquer la femme ou
l'homme qui s'est présenté qui s'est mis
en danger
j'ai gagné et j'ai été battu dans la
salle il y en a beaucoup qui ont gagné
et il y en a beaucoup qui ont été battus
parce que je ne connais personne dans la
vie est linéaire qui n'a jamais connu
des preuves qui n'a jamais mis à genoux
à terre vous savez ce que c'est quand
vous perdez le téléphone qui sonne plus
le député battue qui doit retrouver un
boulot qui peut pas le retrouver
parce qu'il est battu et que les ennemis
d'hier ils ont disparu alors je vois
bien qu'on est dans la société des
experts l'expert dans l'entreprise c'est
en général celui qui n'a jamais créé son
entreprise
l'expert dans la politique c'est en
général celui qui ne s'est jamais
présenté un mandat et chers amis qui
avons nous mis comme tête de liste dans
la région midi-pyrénées
languedoc-roussillon
si ce n'est un membre de la société
civile qui s'est donné beaucoup de mal
je ne suis pas sûr que le résultat était
à la hauteur des espérances
j'aurais pas reprendre l'exemple de ceux
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
enfin un mot sur le cumul des mandats
parce que vous savez au plongeon si moi
je suis très libre dans ma tête je
croyais qu'on aimait le travail on va
pas demander comme première chose
responsables politiques de travailler
moins
vous pensez quelqu'un qui n'a aucune
idée avec deux mandats trouvera des
idées avec à 1
naturellement personne ne veut le cumul
de 4 5 mandats comme ça se faisait
auparavant
mais je veux redire avec détermination
d'un parlementaire a besoin d'un
enracinement local pour garder les pieds
sur terre pour ne pas être un
spécialiste de la législation qui
accumule des lois en se moquant du tiers
comme du quart de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
et est-ce que pardon est ce qu'on a
pensé à ça le mandat unique en quoi
comme conséquence d'augmenter de 50% le
nombre de la classe politique parce que
là où il y avait un député maire là où
il y avait un sénateur maire
là où il y avait un président conseil
général qui était en même temps un
député il y en aura deux
je pense que la modernisation la
république française passe par la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
parce qu'une assemblée pléthorique c'est
une assemblée inaudible et par le
maintien de deux mandats
c'est un débat eh bien vous aurez à
voter le moment venu pareil ce qu'a dit
eric sur le service militaire je pense
que on peut parfaitement défendre le
rétablissement du service militaire
comme sa suppression mais je pense et je
le dis librement que ce fut une erreur
de supprimer le service militaire sont
utilisés larmes du référendum
c'était aux français qu'ils avaient tous
fait leur service national de dire si
oui ou non ils voulaient la suppression
du service militaire et pas uniquement
au parlement